les parents c'est l'enfance de la
majorité des Québécois québécoises
[Musique]
dans ce cours de communication au
Collège de Rosemont peu de préférence
télévisuelle vont faire l'unanimité par
contre la majorité des étudiants
reconnaissent qu'ils écoutent et
regardent beaucoup plus de contenu en
anglais
60% français 20% anglais 20% japonais
55 ans
40% en anglais 40% en espagnol puis 20%
français honnêtement 90% de lait 10 %
français ils vont sur plusieurs
plateformes et disposent de plusieurs
écrans le plus le contrôle de ce qu'on
regarde par exemple quand à la télé
c'est ce que la télé nous offre mais
quand dans notre téléphone notre
ordinateur c'est nous qui peut aller sur
Netflix sur Youtube c'est nous un peu
qui contrôle qu'on va regarder
personnellement moi si j'écoute une
émission de télévision d'une demi-heure
mettons déjà une demi-heure ça va être
long à regarder non-stop puis en plus il
y a des pauses qui entrecoupent c'est
sûr j'aurais arrêté d'écouter j'ai
décroché là
de la France c'est pas du Québec parce
que je trouve qu'il rejoint beaucoup
plus les choses que j'aime une fois de
temps en temps il y a une série qui sort
qui sort qui est pas mal tout le monde
écouter que tout le monde connaît dans
un sens je fais un shooting
[Musique]
m'a changé très très rapidement c'est
même pas c'est même à l'intérieur de
d'une génération c'est on voit déjà une
segmentation énorme entre les jeunes qui
aujourd'hui ont 22 à 22 à 28 ans puis
même les très jeunes enfants moi
ça c'est non scientifique mais ce que
j'observe c'est que le point de bascule
est vraiment dans la génération qui est
née à partir de 2004 2005 parce que là
c'est la génération qui est née avec les
réseaux sociaux numériques les séries
québécoises leur semblent moins visible
sur leur réseau sociaux
c'est pas dessus je suis sur TikTok
c'est pas dessus je suis sur Instagram
c'est pas dessus je vais en entendre
parler si je vais sur Facebook parce que
ma mère repose sauf que je vais pas sur
Facebook parce que ma mère repose fait
que
ce qui va se passer c'est que c'est pas
visible c'est pas accessible donc je
passe à autre chose je fais de
l'accessibilité d'ailleurs si les séries
québécoises étaient sur Amazon Netflix
que je regarde j'ai rendu là ça serait
bien plus facile il y a une perte de
référence culturelle comment oui la note
culture c'est fraise au profit de la
culture américaine c'est pas bénéfique
ni au niveau identitaire ni au niveau
linguistique ni au niveau politique ni
au niveau économique je sais qu'ils ont
mis des films québécois sur Netflix ça
c'est parfait parce que maintenant je
peux j'ai accès plus je regarde tout ce
n'est pas parce qu'un contenu est offert
sur une plateforme numérique qu'il
atteint forcément sa cible Catalina
bricegno croit aussi au travail
d'éducation qu'il faut faire comme on
l'a fait avec l'importance de consommer
localement parallèlement on parle un peu
malhabilement de l'immigration et tout
ça alors que dans les faits c'est un
enjeu culturel c'est un enjeu
socioculturel éducation
éducation culture à la limite éducation
à la culture ce qui manque à l'heure
actuelle le plus c'est une vision
cohérente des partis politiques ont
promis d'investir dans la production des
missions jeunesse
les promesses électorales au même fait
du chemin auprès de certains jeunes que
maintenant sont plus vraiment beaucoup
sur les réseaux sociaux comme les chefs
de parties comme sur TikTok sur TikTok
puis je vois Québec solidaire où je vois
même la CAQ je vois François Lego qui me
parle il me dit le contenu anglophone
des réseaux sociaux a très certainement
un impact sur le recul du français au
Québec mais le retard des vieux
gouvernement à se mettre au diapason des
jeunes et peut-être tout aussi
responsable ici à Louise despaty
Radio-Canada Montréal